today's classic interview is one I did
with Chuck Collins back in 2015 and it's
so relevant to much of the discussion
we're having right now about income
inequality and what policies we should
be looking for in order to improve
society overall because Chuck Collins is
a rich dude who explained why inequality
is bad in no uncertain terms whatsoever
and when we now have a rich dude in the
White House who doesn't really seem to
think that inequality is a problem and
who is not pushing any kind of policy to
deal with the fact that we have this
bigger than ever inequality and lopsided
ownership of wealth in the United States
compare and contrast and of course there
was really no comparison because Chuck
Collins actually knows what he's talking
about and is capable of abstract
thinking something that the current
president hasn't shown himself to be
able to do think about what Chuck
Collins is saying and advocating for in
my interview with him compared to the
doctrine of Trump and his acolytes and
cronies this is my interview with Chuck
from December of 2015 I'm joined today
by Chuck Collins who's an author and
also a senior scholar at the Institute
for Policy Studies in Washington DC he's
also co-founder of wealth for common
good Chuck we've been talking about
income and wealth inequality in the
United States we know some of the
incredible statistics like for example
that the richest 20 Americans own more
wealth than the entire bottom half of
the country I want to talk to you about
the economic and social impact of that
but before give us a sort of summary of
how we even got to such an incredible
gap when it comes to wealth well I've
been tracking this for almost 30 years
so we basically have seen a growing
concentration of wealth at the top I
think there's no single cause there's a
number of reasons why that's happening
but I would argue that probably the
single biggest driver is that various
rules of the economy Tax Policy trade
policy etc have benefited asset owners
at the expense of wage earners and so I
think we're seeing
assets expanding wages being stagnant
for almost 30 years and but it was
really only ten years ago that you know
the median income was 85 in the median
wealth down and this concentration at
the top keeps - just continues to defy
gravity really and when we think about
you know one element we've talked about
is productivity for the average worker
continues to increase in other words the
average worker is producing whether it
be goods or services more than ever
before but as you mentioned their wage
is not going up and that talked to us a
little bit about that right I mean the
additional productivity that workers are
creating is sort of being moved up in a
redistribution of income as some like to
say to do those at the top of the income
brackets and big corporation yeah so I
would say a huge driver is you know
productivity has gone up wages have
stayed low most of that productivity
gain then the wealth and income gains
from that have gone to not just really
the top 1% but what we're seeing really
in the last 8 or 9 years is it's going
to the top one-tenth of 1% who captured
most of the income and wealth gains at
the top so that's clearly a driver and
you know as the French economist Thomas
Piketty has pointed out if you just sort
of if that's the machinery if left
without intervening in any what way
where we're heading is we're seeing
going to a kind of a concentrated wealth
of a sort of a plutocracy where wealth
continues to concentrate wealth and
power continue to concentrate at the top
so we have to do something to intervene
in that inequality cycle so people can
have different opinions as to whether
this is moral or ethical what we see
happening but let's not have that
conversation let's have the conversation
as to what is the economic impact of
such wealth inequality and then whether
it's moral or not becomes sort of
irrelevant if we can make some general
assessments as to whether this is a good
or bad thing for the economy at large so
how can we think about that well one
thing thing is that this concept
wealth actually kind of creates a huge
amount of distortions and and volatility
in the economy so you have real wages
staying flat or falling for most of the
population that means that the aggregate
demand the consumer buying demand of
people at the bottom in the middle is
really not as engaged and then at the
very top you have this unreal
concentration of assets which leads to
sort of some unreal risk-taking meaning
people at the very top I'm talking about
you know the top 1% of households are
starting to move and a portion of their
wealth into more financially speculative
investments investments that get higher
returns than the real economy which
isn't you know returning a lot in terms
of interest or earnings so you have this
twin dynamic you have stagnant wages on
the bottom and then you have a
concentrated wealth at the top looking
more and more venturing into the sort of
speculative arena of the marketplace and
all of that leads to certain volatility
huge volatility so just take the energy
market today or over the last couple of
months you know or real estate in major
urban areas those are all local and
national and global economies that are
that are being distorted by these great
inequities of wealth and as we also know
that it sort of undermines the
traditional measures of growth I mean
the International Monetary Fund is now
showing up at the global level how these
inequalities actually undermine
traditional measures of economic growth
so too much too much inequality is bad
for the economy in a number of ways and
what about the social impact you know
the economic analysis you've done is
very clear we've talked about it before
we've spoken to other economists about
it what about the sort of intangible
social impact of such wealth inequality
well I think what we know is that as
societies become more an equal there is
a breakdown in solidarity where people
no longer feel that they're in the same
boat and it actually increases sort of a
sense of fear and polarization I would
argue in some ways our 2016 presidential
election dynamics where you have a
annex Anders candidate they're both
emerging out of the same phenomena
witches this is what happens when middle
classes collapse when people feel like
the economy is is rigged against them
whatever political analysis they take
with that may send them at different
directions but the underlying problem is
this polarization so I think it leads to
kind of a whole bunch of negative
indicators it's bad for health it's bad
for public health even for very wealthy
people it's bad for social cohesion
it's undermines sort of neighborhoods
when and communities when they're these
volatile and destructive inequities so I
think it sort of pulls in our culture it
moves us in the wrong direction
and in terms of us as a society there's
certain issues we talk about where there
are very clear sort of action items or
asks that the average individual can do
in terms of engaging lawmakers or
engaging with the political system or
society etc with this one it's been more
difficult for us on the program to
figure out what individuals can do I
mean certainly it would be great to
elect more politicians who would put in
policies that would have a sort of
equalizing effect to reduce this drastic
income gap that we have but what can the
average person really do well I think
continuing to talk to their friends and
neighbors about why these inequalities
matter believe it or not is very
important because I think as a society
we've gone from ten years ago and we
really didn't talk about it to a broader
recognition and connect the dots these
inequalities really do affect the
quality of life for all of us then I
think there's a sort of three ways to
think about the solutions there's the
things that raised the floor like
raising the minimum wage creating a
better sort of social safety net that's
what a many you know Canada and other
European countries the reason they have
less inequality is they have a higher
floor there's also things that we can do
to level the playing field
we shouldn't have one tax code for the
wealthy and one for everyone else
one for global corporations and one for
everyone else we should have a level
playing field in terms of those rules
and I would say we dare to challenge
there though in that those who have sort
of set up the system the way
it's setup have no real interest in
allowing it to change right those who
benefit from that system would prevent
it from changing to the extent that
they're able yea we're sort of in a
little bit of a locked-in position which
is the power of concentrated wealth has
captured our certainly at the national
level the level captured our electoral
system so it's very hard to talk about
rule changes that would meaningfully
reduce this inequality but I think if
you look under at the undercurrent think
about the number of students that are
holding debt there's a there's a
political constituency look at polls
that show that that the public supports
taxing incomes on millionaires seventy
five percent of the of the public now
supports those kinds of policies so
there's a a realignment happening at the
base which I think will lead to a
political realignment eventually not in
the short term because you have a
Congress that's pretty much beholden to
the donor class that's why I saying I
think we also have to sort of put on the
table policies that may not actually
pass today but we sort of build an
understanding of why they're important
like taxing progressive inheritance
taxes taxing higher incomes at a certain
level there's a piece in The New York
Times today talk that looks at the
aggressive tax avoidance of people
really in the top one percent so we need
to restore the progressivity of the tax
system that may not be wildly popular or
politically feasible in the short term
but we've got to keep beating that drum
eventually there will be a realignment
either that or we can become a kind of
society we really don't want to be I'll
tell everybody once again we've been
speaking with Chuck Collins he's an
author he's a senior scholar at the
Institute for Policy Studies in
Washington DC and the co-founder of
wealth for common good Chuck thank you
so much for being on with us today thank
you David good chat chatting with you